el amor es un crimen
debo absolutamente amar a una persona de
otro sexo porque esta sociedad no me
rechaza
el problema viene de mí o de las leyes
de este país
después de cinco años de cuestionamiento
puedo responder a algunas de estas
preguntas sobre todo a mi detención en
la prisión de búlgaras donde estuve
encarcelado durante nueve días
el artículo 489 del código penal
marroquí castiga a las relaciones
sexuales entre personas del mismo sexo
con hasta 3 años de cárcel
arriesgar le condenaron siendo menor de
edad hoy defiende sus derechos y escribe
su primer libro en el que reivindica su
existencia como forma de resistencia
ante la criminalización
nuestra visibilidad y nuestra existencia
y resistencia contra estos artículos
y el trabajo que todas las asociaciones
grupos y colectivos alguien lo mueve la
causa
la justicia
el cambio no se da si
el cambio llega con trabajo constancias
y eso es lo que estamos haciendo aquí en
marruecos ahora
y el excepcional
comuna es la primera web sería en árabe
marroquí que representa la comunidad
lgtb y más sus creadoras forman parte
del colectivo nasa with un espacio
liderado por mujeres queer que trabajan
por la transformación social desde el
arte y la defensa de derechos
y
no podemos vivir abiertamente de la
forma que quisiéramos en nuestro país
por eso creamos nasa billete para tener
espacios seguros espacios donde podemos
resistir y ser quienes queremos ser
en 2020 específicamente una campaña de
austin
una influencia que tiene muchos
servidores llamó a descargarse una
aplicación de citas gay sis
estábamos en confinamiento y la gente
empezó a descargarse la aplicación de
citas y days para descubrir a personas
de su alrededor
expedían fotos y las envían a la red
a pesar de toda la violencia la
comunidad logró organizarse la seguridad
y otros colectivos lgtb
fundaron la alianza 489 intentamos
unificar nuestros esfuerzos para
trabajar contra la homofobia el gmt una
obvia transfobia y bifobia al artículo
489 del código penal le sigue el 490 que
castiga el sexo fuera del matrimonio y
otros artículos morales heredados del
código napoleónico del siglo 19 impuesto
durante la colonización francesa cada
año alrededor de 15 mil personas son
perseguidas en marruecos por delitos
morales
el artículo 490 del código penal castiga
a las relaciones sexuales entre parejas
fuera del matrimonio
pero este no no especifica si las
relaciones son consentidas o no
consentidas
pueden ser casos de abusos prostitución
trata de personas
karima es una de las fundadoras de
marroquíes fuera de la ley 'esto 490 una
plataforma que promueve la derogación de
los artículos morales lo hacen a través
de las redes sociales donde si tiene
cabida un debate que está lejos de
trasladarse a la esfera institucional
antes de las últimas elecciones enviaron
un cuestionario a todos los partidos
para conocer su posición ante el tema de
las libertades individuales sin éxito
hubo un solo partido que respondió a una
de las cuestiones que le planteamos
nosotras ahora nos centramos en la
movilización de la gente de la juventud
consideran que es importante divulgar el
origen colonial de los artículos morales
porque mucha gente cree que emanan de
fuentes islámicas
no es para nada lo que prevé el islam en
materia del sexo extramarital o
corrupción moral así que los orígenes
son coloniales
la juventud marroquí tiene una
conciencia diferente y quizás otro
marruecos es posible en marruecos de
libertades y derechos individuales
en el instituto francés de marrakech se
dan cita la ilustradora de inef así que
el creador de podcast sufría en jinán y
dos voces muy conocidas entre la
juventud marroquí que reivindican la
igualdad y la libertad sexual
no hay que olvidar que esas leyes están
ligadas a la colonización
impuestas por francia tras la
colonización
hay que saber que hay países que fueron
colonizados por otros países como
jordania o egipto y no tienes leyes que
criminalizan la libertad sexual y la
homosexualidad
voy a llamar
[Música]
no hay nada de malo es decir soy un
hombre y soy homosexual
soy un hombre en situación de
discapacidad
o soy un hombre trans
creo que hoy en marruecos somos capaces
de construir un debate
un debate al que la juventud no está
dispuesta a renunciar una lucha latente
de parte de una sociedad que muta frente
a unas instituciones que consideran
aisladas en otros tiempos